absolutely I tried my best
just kidding we've scoured the city for
the hottest new fitness disciplines
these are the workouts everyone's
talking about
we've got turf set white.i tabata yoga
and boot camp it's your body
this is fighting team I'm Mike that
created Surf's Up
this is your at-home surf set leg
workout on this three-minute surf set
workout we're gonna go through some leg
exercises we're going to start pretty
much with the quads and glutes first and
then we're gonna work into a full leg
exercises so the first one I want to go
through is just gonna be your basic
squat you want to get warmed up all
we're gonna do is go right down we're
gonna work this through weight through
the heels
alright this next move is just gonna be
a sumo squat a little bit wider this
time I'm gonna get a little deeper left
knee up right up to that elbow right
knee up that right elbow last one I want
to go through here was just with quads
and glutes alright it's gonna be
actually a squat jump running from all
the way down and explode up right use
those hands to throw your weight up and
land nice and soft the next series we're
gonna be working on is lunges call these
warrior ones okay so you gonna bring
that left foot back we're gonna bring
that right elbow right down to the
inside of the knee bring that left arm
all the way up to the ceiling come back
from here we can alternate legs but for
this first series I want you to just do
the right side but this next one these
are called skate lunges so what you're
gonna do is you're gonna bring that left
leg behind that right leg alright and
now you're gonna explode over balance
and catch just like like I'm pretending
I'm Apolo Ohno here some ice skating Sam
okay exactly
the idea is focus on the quads right a
little dynamic stabilization so it's
next one these are called split squat
jumps so we're gonna be switching that
left legs coming forward switch and now
you're catching their weight in your
quads
alright so that's three sets of squats
three sets of lunges each for 90 seconds
a little of 3 minutes sounds good
awesome see first ones up we're just
gonna work on a few squats make sure
those knees don't come over the tops of
the toes okay all right
exhaling on the way up okay inhaling on
the way down
all right now let's try and move right
in to those sumo squats there you go
keep that balance work on that balance
yeah well working in that that 4x4
square you got right there is probably
perfect size for you I'm gonna go right
into exploring squat jumps they're
coming well knees if they
behind the toes all right you're gonna
push up weights gonna be in the heels
explode all the way up use ur hands as
you come up so down make sure Lana nice
and soft the balls of the feet the next
set we're going onto is the lunge series
first one we're going to start with is
gonna be the warrior lunge so I want to
start with that right foot bring that
left leg back as you come down bring
that left arm up look up through the
palm return come back to that first
position looking up over the palm of
your hand all right
lunge skaters start on that right side
even just here finding that balance and
now you're gonna explode all the way
over so you can get deeper try and stay
in that same plane nice and balanced
send that left and right knee as you hit
it's really working your balance a lot
these are called split squat jumps left
foots coming back so now we're just
gonna go on a traditional lunge to start
so as we jump up we're switching here we
go fifteen seconds that'll get the
glutes going quads hamstrings calves for
that stuff I don't know is that step
fifteen seconds no but it was close when
we repeat that whole series that lunch
here's one more time
it's gonna wrap the workout for three
minutes nice job thanks so to recap
we're starting with warm-up squats
followed by sumo squats finishing that
series off with squat jumps fifteen
seconds of peace repeat that twice for a
total of 90 seconds then we move into
lunges starting with warrior lunges then
moving on to skater lunges and finishing
off with split squat jump lunges say
that right all right
twice fifteen seconds of peace for a
total of 90 seconds again that gives you
your three minute pocket surf set
workout make sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any other fighting
weight episodes